i notice you it's mainly just you on
your channel do you want to like ever do
collabs with guests or anything like
that i
do but i get it maybe that's just me
being i'm i'm picky
because i have noticed you know even
there's people i like like you
or or like i have a friend named austin
burke he also has a youtube channel i
don't i don't know
austin you know our heavy spoilers kevin
but like i noticed with those collab
videos
the retention isn't there they'll
they'll severely go down just because
it's like inviting a new person in bed
they just don't like it or something and
so like i get i get real picky about
bringing people on my channel but i i i
want to
i want to because i think it's fun
so you're not going to invite me on your
channel that's what you're telling me
that's great
john maynard
[Music]
what's going on reject nation um
i got with me today a person
who i've wanted to collab with i've
wanted to
hang out with i've wanted to be my
personal friend
for so long we talked publicly for the
first time on social media
where we added each other and stuff and
then messages
and then we got each other's phone
number but this is the first time
him and i have ever actually
seen we haven't even talked on the phone
with each other before have we no i
don't think we have we haven't
oh man that's your fault
we got chris from 3c films here today
thank you so much for having me greg i i
didn't know if i'm really a worthy guess
enough for your channel but for all you
who are clicking right now
if you didn't come over from my channel
i appreciate you no you're the you're
the bomb man anytime we've covered one
of your videos people are always like
oh chris from 3c films is the best he's
the best at what he does
that's so good i don't know how i got
here i think you got the great blend of
providing your own personality
humor and then providing like great
information
on top of that i feel like for certain
channels who do like breakdowns and news
and stuff people will come
primarily for that and i feel like
people really come for both when it
comes to you
and i think that's part of what makes
you so special man hopefully yeah
no i think that's all 100 sure there's a
hundred channels doing that you know
where they just
they bring you the news i think the same
way i did i tried my best to be a little
different but i think i just
i just i don't know film some videos
that might embarrass me down the line
um so what's going on right now is it's
may and uh i was like you know there's
so many youtubers that i talk about
or i talk with sometimes rarely but i
don't actually
really know as well and i'm like i just
want to really get to know some of these
people
and what better way to have a genuine
conversation than with the camera
pointed at you
yeah you didn't give me any free
questions no
real topic it's just putting my face on
the camera and seeing what happens
so how big is your dick chris
[Laughter]
the camera's not big enough to support
what i'm about to show you guys the
reason you only see my top hat
i'll admit though i haven't interviewed
anyone like major
but out of anyone i've interviewed
interviewed some directors and
and stuff did you do mortal kombat and
the willy's wonderland director
those are more major than 3c films trust
me yeah but you're you're
no man that's my point is though is i'm
weird even though we've talked on text
many times i'm weirdly more nervous
about this one than any of those for
some reason
i don't know i feel like i've been easy
to talk to guy i think i just really
admire you
and that's why thanks man that's nice of
you yeah
i just want this to go well i'm so
nervous that what if we're not friends
it's going to go good it's going to go
good youtubers yeah
the whole time but speaking of kissing
each other's butt i love
your intros so much you know like
for our reaction your flash one for
example if you guys haven't seen this
flash one
um he he what he you did the
thing on the toilet where he ran out of
toilet paper can i just play it i'm just
gonna play it i'm just going to use it
oh you have it okay
here we go play play the footage right
oh damn it i'm out of toilet paper again
[Music]
and that [ __ ] just broke me like it was
so
funny do you ever have any of these
prepped in advance or do you just come
up with them on the fly
that day because they always have a
spontaneous flair to them sometimes i do
think ahead of them mainly like for the
spider-man ones because like those are
like i know spider-man news will always
be happening just because the way
everything's getting leaked with that
movie but
uh so i try to think ahead for
spider-man because this is the most
difficult for
like the flash or sonic or any other
kind of movie i'm passionate about
they they usually are on the fly and
that kind of ruins how fast i put out a
video because you know in the news
game you have to be quick if you want
views on that and stuff
luckily i've gotten to a spot now where
like i don't have to be the first one
i'll i'll still have people watch me
thankfully yeah they're that cocky son
of a [ __ ]
i don't need to be first i don't need to
be first
[Laughter]
do you have one that you would say is
your personal favorite or like
top three favorite intros yeah i did a
spider-man one maybe i'll send it to you
after all all this is done so you could
look at it but it was one you remember
the scene in spider-man uh two where
he's like
shooting webs to like stop the train and
slow it down
ah what a beautiful morning man
oh spiderman saving the train that's
good for him let's see
i laughed so hard at that it's probably
so dumb that i left up my own intro but
when i made that i was so proud i i
think your intros genuinely are like
that's a big part of what makes what
makes your videos shine so much
i feel like those are often more
commented than your actual the rest of
your videos a lot of the time yeah
yeah some people say they come just to
see the intro but it's the curse part
where it's like
if i can't think of anything funny i
don't want to force it or just do
something
bottom line or it feels not funny so
sometimes i'll have a video just happen
like today was a dc one where i have no
idea what to do so i just
just regular hey guys how's it going and
then i'll get hundreds of comments
disappointed i didn't have a funny intro
and i'm just like i didn't have an idea
guys
i think there's a lot that we can talk
about that only i feel like
other people who do youtube could really
identify with
i feel like we'll probably get into some
heavy stuff but then you know we'll keep
it
we'll keep it fairly light i honestly
didn't prep any questions i feel like i
can just talk with you
oh thanks man yeah now i'll just freely
answer here but yeah
there's a lot of stuff like you were
talking a about paul heavy spoilers
and all that i i also uh message him all
the time and we just talk about things
that only youtubers
would understand with the stress of the
job or making content like today with
them announcing new dc fandom it's like
that's awesome that's going to be a hell
of a day though for us
creators just because they released like
four trailers
these posters they announced this movie
and uh you just have to post video after
video and you know like after three
videos youtube just stops
uh notifying your audience or whatever
and so it's just like if they show up
they show up
what i find is very common i guess i'm
going for the jugular right here
what i find is very common with
youtubers
especially ones that i get to know over
time is that there's an issue with
comparing yourself to other people and i
as and i think it's because it's so easy
to
it's like before we hopped on the stream
uh i mean this uh whatever we're doing
we were talking about like oh big enough
for your channel but i'm like oh but
dude no like like it since
december the real rejects has been great
but this we're shooting this on april
28th and
this has easily been my most
underperforming week
in like the last four months like it's
been like
and i feel like sometimes my emotions
are based off
of how well my last video did i am
the same way if i brought up my
girlfriend she could test to you if i'm
having a good or bad week on youtube
because it relies on my mood and
how i feel if i'm having like i think i
just went on a four-day streak of not
posting any
videos because there just wasn't any
news or anything to talk about and
i just like i just end up staring at the
wall like you're gonna lose it
they're gonna disappear on you you're
not gonna have anybody left and i just
i crumble myself in that state and then
when i get something to talk about it's
like
my mood changes and i'm happy for that
day until i have to post another video i
admire that about what your channel that
a
lot
a lot of people i watch i feel like
there's such a reliability like with you
i like i know that when i turn on your
video it's going to be a damn good video
do you do do you script all your content
or is it all
or is it improvisable i know i respect
people who who script it and write it
down and plan it out ahead of time but
um
a lot of stuff is just like well i
obviously like read the article or
whatever the news is about and
do some extra research if i could think
of it but most times it's just off the
top of my head what i'm thinking about
and wow really you see yeah you guys
wait it's so i don't script uh obviously
with what we have to do mainly sometimes
we just
like do a video like didn't you for like
the new son of kong movie that they're
coming out with you guys just sat there
and talked
no i mean sometimes we have like bullet
points we want to hit which is rare
i think that helps when you're like
making chapters and stuff in your video
but i thought for you for sure you'd at
least like have an
outline for what you're going to cover
because of how you how your your videos
are structured so well
you don't even outline your videos or
are you just kind of going off the dome
no
i think i've just done it so much where
like i just have a general outline in my
mind of what i'm going to say
and do that i just i said not not to be
cocky or anything
but yeah sometimes it just it just flows
out you know
that's i don't mean to keep this is the
most
self-indulgent pretentious
conversation to youtubers talking about
the struggles of being a youtuber right
now
seriously though i i actually think that
is really impressive because your videos
have such a great structure to them
i imagine you got at least like when
you're
okay let me ask you this when you when
you edit it is it is that the linear
order of how you
filmed it or are you rearranging your
clips no that's
so wild to me isn't it really impressive
yeah that's because there's like a
perfect structure
like i'll watch the whole like because
youtube is based so much off of
watch time it's really easy for me to at
least watch 45 to 50 percent of your
video
like it's really easy for me to hit that
mark
it's like for for trailer reactions for
us most people
more than half of the audience will
actually click off after uh
the reaction is done yeah they don't
stick around for those two or three
minutes of you like
so that was a good trailer i kind of
like this part or they don't stick
around for that
no and that affects like the the
recommended like for for conjuring three
it's like we talked for like 10 minutes
after the reaction
wow and then people say all we do is
react and i'm like
no but you stop the video but i noticed
like our watch time increases if we like
when we cover your videos when we pause
and play like actually mixing in the
commentary in between but back to what i
was saying before
do you do you haven't do you struggle at
all with like comparing yourself to
others does that seem to be my general
that's my general problem that i have
these days i mean
i i'll admit it there's probably others
who do it as well but i do my weekly
checkup on
competitors friends you know like uh you
guys uh
heavy spoilers um other channels out
there that i think
do news as well i'll i'll do my weekly
like what videos a day post how many
views a day getting then i'll
hurt myself i didn't decide to talk on
that topic or anything like that but
it used to be way more toxic in the
beginning because especially i wasn't
getting views no one was watching me and
i was just so
angry i was like why aren't they
watching me i'm funny i'm just as good
as these
guys out there but um
you just have to let that go you can put
yourself in a dark place really
comparing yourself or saying you're not
good enough or whatever and just
have to learn to to just know what
you're good at now because i i used to
do
ending explains a lot where you know a
horror movie would come out
i'd do an indian explain and stuff like
that and that's how i
got in contact with like heavy spoilers
because we both were doing at the same
time and
i would beat him once and he beat me and
then i don't know what happened he
perfected the game and shot up way up
high and i was just down here never
reaching the views that he did i just
was like i'm not good at this he can
keep doing it
i'ma shift my focus and i can't get mad
at other creators either that's one
thing
where it's like even though i compare
myself i never want to hate or be that
secret disliker on the channel
because that's that's not good if
anything i feel like i would get bad
karma from that i feel like
um you know something bad will happen to
my video or something
that's a great call because uh i i
i don't think i've ever i might have
done it
once in my life but i don't even know
what it was i don't think i've ever hit
the dislike button on anyone's video
i admit i did it early on i i was i was
a disliker early on
i'm not gonna lie i'm not perfect i was
a dislike
but i think i was a dislike
[Laughter]
but it was always jealousy or or more if
not it was the
extremely click-baity people that
promised something in the
title or thumbnail and didn't deliver
and got tons of views
and i'm just like how are they getting
away with this is there like a specific
type of criticism or hate comment that
you'll get
that will really that kind of seems to
like provoke you on
on a subconscious level dessert i'll get
i'll get comments you know that the
general oh you're fat
you're not funny or um i don't i don't
know something or like why do you have
all these toys aren't you an adult in
your mama's basement or something those
don't bother me it's
it's like the comments where they
actually give constructive
criticism that be something like you
know i was a subscriber for like six
months but what you said right there
just lost me as a viewer you have no
idea what you're talking about it's like
it's the comments that it's like you
know these people have a brain it's not
just the idiots
who say mean things to say mean things
it's like that's those are the ones that
hit me the most is those not just like
i know they make you feel like a family
member's leaving your friend doesn't
want to be
friends with you anymore and i'm like i
don't even remember you
but my feelings are hurt now exactly
that's how i feel
i think a lot of people don't realize
just how
sensitive the world is of uh of be
of doing youtube it's weird you know
like it's important to not
have an ego and it's also important to
not get overly
defensive it's like someone will attack
you but then that's also like poking at
your ego because then you want to get
defensive and then your ego then then
you get then if you get defensive then
you get called out for being defensive
right it's like
this this yeah i've had my moments where
i i
comment back to a hate comment and then
i keep coming back to it adding more and
more and
rewarding
with kindness if they say something mean
and it does hit me just be like all
right i'm sorry
i think you're doing great congrats on i
know we've been talking for 20 minutes
but congrats on 300 000 subscribers by
the way
i appreciate that i just you know the
funny thing is about subscribers is back
when you're starting you think
subscribers is what's gonna guarantee
you're like huge success
but it's like it really is just kind of
like a nice little starter
of an audience to shoot out your video
to but subscribers don't matter all that
much as far as like views and
and retention and even financially on
youtube subscribers
usually don't mean that much so i'm very
happy i got 300
000 i would want more but i learned to
stop being obsessed with that number
because i was on like social blade all
the time
staring at my stats and seeing how many
people would get on
youtube no i bet it [ __ ] you up yeah
the the
on the on on the youtube phone oh people
might not know is like on
on youtube that they got the dashboard
and you could it's like if you're
if your view count goes up like if
you're averaging like 30 000
like there was a time where it was like
oh damn we're getting 15 000 views of
video that's great
but now our view count is expected to be
higher because of what we've been
getting the last few months
so now if we get like 20 thousand views
youtube's like
your video is way underperforming it's
horrible too that they added that
feature that
youtube will literally say it to you
this video sucks man what did you do
like it's not that aggressive but they
say people don't care about this video
focus on what you did differently or
something and it's just like i know
youtube leave me alone
but i'm like it's also a spider-man
video what did i do wrong
that's something awesome you could talk
about a topic that's trending and then
out of nowhere just doesn't hit and
you're like what
i thought this was i thought this was a
banger subject it's very easy to get
like
to seek validation from like view count
it's something that really messes with
my
my mental health uh a lot if i'm being
honest
and i think as you can attest if you're
personally not
feeling good or like positive or
something i don't know if it's a good
energy
that that can translate into a video
when you're on campus because you do
everything yourself right like you don't
yeah i don't
get it or an editor or anything like
that i i did it all myself taught myself
final cut and all that stuff
um even then i still do like the bare
basics of final cut and
i try adding more stuff in there but
yeah
when it's all yourself it could be even
more draining because i think to myself
do i need an editor
now am i at that level or do i i need to
hire someone else or
how do people get spot i still don't
even know how people get sponsorships i
get lucky
if i get an email someone offering it
but i don't know how to seek them out
i'll refer someone to you yeah i just
get emails i i've never
i don't think i've ever sought one out
personally i think they just wait for
somebody to come
right here they come to me yeah
yeah oh my god i got like boatloads of
emails yeah
i got my first shadow legends offer and
i was like whoa
guess i finally made it
don't read the comments on that i know
i did yeah i was debating what would you
say though is like your real passion
though
uh okay let's talk about like film wise
do you want to go beyond youtube do you
want to do
like it's like the fact that you can
make these intros on your own
is pretty impressive so yeah you want to
do this you can see the editing involved
it's not that impressive
but um it looks impressive man i
appreciate that a lot you'd be surprised
that i actually filled them up with my
phone a lot of those green screen intros
um
i went through the phases i was a little
kid like he was fascinated with like jim
carrey and was like i want to be the
funny guy i want to be an actor and
find out how hard it is to get in that
world especially if you live in texas
nowhere near
the hollywood game then i was like okay
i'll be a director or i'll be a writer
i'll be something in hollywood and ended
up with youtubing what i would like is
is
short films i would i would like to try
short films whether
you know just just to see if i have it
in me i'm not trying to go artsy
or or black and white character driven i
just like it to be entertaining
you know i i know i can never make like
a david fincher movie or something like
that but if i could make you laugh i'd
be happy with that
i feel like you should set out to make a
dave adventure movie and then get
oh i could get a whole bunch of
unintentional laughter throughout that
should be your dream right there what i
love about what you do is
it's like uh i mean i know it's like
obviously hopping around like the
franchise big ones monster verse
superheroes but you also seem to have a
big love
and you don't seem it's apparent you
have a big love for horror as well
that's kind of the horror peeps is what
got my channel going but i've loved how
hard since i was a kid you know i was
lucky enough to have a dad that i didn't
even know
movies were rated r and restricted and
only certain ages could see them until
like i was like
15 when i wanted to go see a rated r
movie and i couldn't or whatever
uh my dad was always cool about letting
me see those kind of movies he would
just always give me
a small pep talk before the movie's like
okay well we're about to watch
not appropriate don't ever do this in
real life
now enjoy it like it was it was always
like that which was nice
and obviously i haven't and i haven't
killed no one but
it will say and it's also an underserved
i think i don't want to call it like a
market but that's how i think in terms
of youtube and business-wise is
uh there are a lot of good hard channels
out there but i didn't think there was
any
light-hearted fun channels a lot of the
hard channels out there were very dark
and
serious and you know real critiquey and
i don't know i just wanted to add some
fun to it would you say you're like your
top
horror movies are okay so like scream uh
nightmare on elm street and uh child's
play this is very basic i'm not going to
say
psycho you see albert hitchcock's hidden
movie
yeah see this deep cut movie that you
might not have heard of german you you
wouldn't know about it
yeah you wouldn't have it exactly but
you touched on something that i
i wonder if we identify with was like
one of your main ways to bond with your
father
uh growing up was was was that was it
movies
my dad my dad is responsible for the
movie knowledge i got in my head you
know he
he actually worked at blockbuster uh you
know back when that was a thing and
it was during like the transitioning
from vhs to dvds
so like every other week he would come
home with just like a box of vhs tapes
and
i'd just be popping them in seeing what
was there or i remember like
he would randomly like bring up a movie
he's like talking about rocky and he's
like oh you haven't seen rocky
that same weekend he'd rent all the
rocky movies we'd marathon them indiana
jones
all that so definitely owe a lot of
credit to my dad for
letting me get into this and all that
and he's very happy this is what i do
because
at first he wasn't happy when i told him
i wanted to quit college to do this
oh you said you didn't go to college
either to i did i did my
associate so i got my two year and then
i i was like my first semester into like
university big classroom then
auditorium seating and a professor and i
just couldn't do it
it didn't feel like me
and luckily this worked out if not i'd
be working like at a call center or
something like that
my dad and i that was the main thing we
could talk about
was movies and he was kind of similar to
what you're saying is like he
i was not censored like uh
i i i can ask how old you are i'm 26
26. oh man i'm 30.
i feel so totally for your differences
you see it when you're four years older
you'll know what i guess
i'm already panicking that myself these
are almost gone i'm like damn
you seem like a bit of an anxious
individual if i'm being really okay
i am yeah
well it's something that i'll notice on
camera like i'll see you like
i'm like he's got the leg shake going oh
yeah i'm horrible yeah
i got uh oh my leg shake obvious on
camera i'm so sorry
i feel like i'll notice it because i'll
notice when i'm editing myself doing it
or noticing when i'm editing john doing
it i don't know why
yeah i've had people back when you could
sit next to strangers at a theater
i've had an old lady tell me can you
stop that where my leg is just shaking
i guess the vibration is carrying over
to our seat
yeah like i just do as i'm consciously i
don't even know but i guess i am anxious
you're my therapist
greg that's what i wanted to do i wanted
to go on youtube
there to be therapy for everyone here
but yeah i mean like with my with my dad
um yeah i think scream i remember um
i would go i must have been like six
years old or something
every sunday after church i would grew
up catholic
uh we would get oh did we get uh hell
yeah
i mean heavens yes uh
you could just feel it right every
sunday after church i would just put on
scream in the living room
i had a vhs tape of it i must have been
six years old so
yeah i wasn't i wasn't a censored guy at
all
so i always think of like that tarantino
interview where he was like losing his
[ __ ] on that one lady
over like because it's cool jan oh that
yeah that's what would you say somebody
like your favorite uh filmmakers are uh
i mean i i really
enjoyed wes craven uh david fincher like
i was
mentioning i always hate when i get put
on the spot because i feel like it's
like
it's like determining you're my first
opinion
my favorite yeah
just if you make a good movie i i i like
yeah um i guess
edgar wright is one i get excited for
like i try to think of the directors
that
it doesn't matter what the movie's about
if they're attached i'm like well i want
to see that
so if you had do you have any if i i no
i have no favorite filmmakers uh
they all suck in my opinion
i mean i i've always i mean yeah i i
think maybe just because of like where i
grew up and growing up on tarantino he's
always been like one of my favorites
yeah uh i'd like i'm like the the cliche
answers scorsese
david fincher the usual when uh
nicholas windenreffen gets it right i'm
really into that though
drive is one of my all-time favorite
movies and when i used to smoke
cigarettes it was because i would watch
ryan gosling smoke cigarettes
i was very much influenced by that man
there's a lot of things movies
influenced us because of back to future
i only wear nikes just because he made
them look
so cool and now you only smoke
cigarettes
two very positive influences
i'd say the nike is pretty damaging to
your health though you might you might
want to step back from the nikes
would you ever want to go into acting
yourself because you're pretty
comfortable on camera yes but i
i need to shed a few pounds or something
get get my teeth fixed or something yeah
i used to think i was the handsomest man
online and then
i scroll through tick tock for a little
bit and there's just way more beautiful
people out there
it says we're going back to the
comparing thing i feel like we both have
this yeah we have this struggle with
compare what's your ethnicity by the way
i am mexican hundred percent no mixing
i'm a pure blood mexican
that's and are you the only one who
actually like pursued
something to do with film uh yeah the
rest of the family i'm the oldest so the
rest of them is barely graduating high
school figuring out their lives and
stuff so i'm the
i'm the only one is it like a big
phantom usually the cliches mexican
families are huge
yeah it it it is big and i have like
split because my parents divorced i had
another cliche to the list
so then mexicans always getting divorced
yeah so like i have some on my mom's
side my dad's side and stuff but
still the oldest and yeah all of them
are still so yeah
say like in total uh five siblings oh
wow do any of them ever
like come to you hoping to get into
youtube themselves and
maybe ask you for some advice no if
anything i'm the one encouraging them
just because like
i think even though like i'm a movie
channel if they have an aspiration
like i have some sisters if they wanted
to get like in the makeup or i don't
know dress up
i don't know what the girls really want
to do but i put on makeup
i know i know the system of the
algorithm well enough to if they tell me
what they want to do
i could be like i could get you there i
can make you some money
took five years but i'll get you there
oh wow you've been doing this for five
years
yes channel started in 2000 in april
2016. okay so i actually just hit
my five-year anniversary and then you
start like the momentum i
i discovered you during the pandemic and
i feel like
really i feel like you had what was the
first video you saw of me how did you
find me
i always think that's funny to find out
i
my god i don't maybe spider-man related
i'd have been watching you for i've been
watching you for for a while i i usually
listen to people
like i rarely watch the videos and then
one day like
i started watching you
i didn't even listen i just lost you
that's fine i haven't even mentioned it
but i've actually been a real rejects
fan
way back like how long how old is your
channel now is it past the 10 year or is
it close to the 10.
close to we did we started uh i think
right at the end of 2012. my earliest
memory of your channel and i hope i'm
not getting it wrong that'll be so
embarrassing
because i think you made like a rap disc
or you made a
i i don't know i remember that correctly
i felt like you made a
some rap song and i just remember like i
thought it was a reaction
i just remember seeing am i right or is
that am i making that oh no when i was
going by the like the right right days
that i was like just [ __ ] around with
like i really i write a lot of poetry
but i don't know how to rap and i and i
have like
sometimes i i make the mistake of
experimenting
on camera without really testing the
waters prior
so i'll just be like yeah let me just
translate some poetry to some songs but
i didn't know how to
at the time i didn't even know how to
hit on a beat it was like so
but my first hey it was bold man it was
bold i remember i watched it i was like
oh he could do more than react
yeah he could kind of rhyme i guess i
i wrote a a one that was like a ryan
gosling rap song
about and it's just pretty much a
hardcore homoerotic
about me just wanting to have sex with
ryan
it's just like the whole song right
there then i did like some serious [ __ ]
after that but
like a reactor diss on eventually i
learned how to get on beat but i was
like
what am i doing i don't want to do this
i'm not this guy
yeah i want to get back into my passions
but it's funny that's how like a
youtuber thinks because even now
i think a lot like with youtube is i
always have to pivot or i have to do
something new and fresh you know i don't
feel like people will always want to
hear me
uh talk the news or anything like that
maybe they will but like i i've thought
about like what if i do some like parody
songs
maybe maybe i can learn so maybe one day
you'll see me embarrass myself
what i'd like to see you do is like do a
complete full-on
sketch which is really hard to do and
you need help
because like yeah babe we've done it's
been a long time since we've done like a
full-on
sketch none of them have ever gotten
like crazy views but the response is
always like
so like we did one for i think the last
full-on sketch was
probably our avengers end game intro or
oh really
or was it a jigs we did one that was a
saw parody
that [ __ ] took a lot of work
was it worth it and the end reviews uh
not for views but
for the people who saw it they can they
quite enjoy
love that and i but i feel like that's
that's a little bit more of what i want
i don't know any that's the thing is
like with an art it's weird because now
there are kids who
who grow up like my fiance works at a
school
and there are kids who grow up now who
who are like
i want to be a youtuber and and i don't
know about when i was growing up
to like i i i wasn't i don't know what
this wasn't a career option i mean i
remember
being in middle school and seeing like
the early youtube videos and stuff like
that thinking this is cool
i never thought i'd actually be one
myself who are like some of the
youtubers that you actually
uh watch like who would you say you
watch regularly now or
regularly see that's another thing with
me and i
it's probably shallow for admitting it
once i started doing youtube
i got very selective with who i watched
because i was just like i'd get mad at
myself like
like i like i like new rock stars and i
like watching them i think eric boss is
cool and all
so i just watched their easter egg
videos and sometimes i do easter egg
videos i'm just like
ugh how much they're so good they have a
whole team yeah
i just i get more mad than entertain so
i tend to watch stuff that is like way
out of like the movie zone just like
a podcast or two or anything like that
oh like who
i don't know if i want to say like i
enjoy h3h3 but then sometimes they just
get real controversial or real uh
real saucy where it's like i can't
really associate myself with that
that's another fear i have man in in
this era of being canceled is like i'm
always where i don't want to make an
apology video i don't ever want to say
something to offend anybody or hurt
anybody and i don't know why i always
have that fear but i'm not i don't have
any like
malice thoughts or anything like that oh
no i understand what you mean i
completely get it but i hate drama i
don't want to ever be part of drama i
don't ever want to be making a video
about somebody or someone make a video
about me
once in a while like i'll do the the
vain thing in like google
on that youtube my name and i put like
recently update
uploaded and like a couple weeks ago i
had like just this random eight-year-old
make a video about how i was the worst
youtuber ever i just watched this
i was like but like his reasons were so
like
unfound and i don't want that's why like
i didn't even want to like something i'd
never respond to or anything like that
and i don't want to blame the kid he
has his opinions but he was like i said
you know the the mask
and other members like pennywise will be
in space jam 2 and he just did not
believe me he's like
that makes no sense why are they in
there 3c films is a liar
stuff like that and i'm just like okay
well that's interesting
but like i fear something like that
happening someday you know
it's just like 3c films is the worst
channel ever and here's why and it's
like a
i don't know a 25 year old man talking
about
yeah yeah i mean i've had my days of
youtube drama and
i don't i don't like it either i i mean
i i really
yeah i hate it and then if i ever person
like i remember
oh it was one of those news articles
about uh
like this wasn't like a personal drama
one that i was involved with but there
was
like when i covered a dramatic story it
was robert pattinson
his diva on set and his thinking and
like him and matt reeves
and uh like he lied about catching uh uh
the virus right
that that was the that was the click and
then of course like immediately i did it
there's dislikes and people are like why
are you covering this
but i'm like but if you watch the video
the whole time all we're doing is
making fun of how ridiculous
this is and how people will do v there
are channels who will do
serious videos about this and i'm like
this is the stupidest thing in the world
why are people taking this seriously
yeah
and that's more of my like uh my angle
on it you seem like you're a pretty
it seems like you try to keep a positive
head on your shoulders is there is there
anything you'd like to do
like i'll still be negative and i'll say
my honest opinion on stuff i never want
to be positive just
like always be positive because i think
then that's just as bad as always being
negative
um but i also if i know something's bad
sometimes i just don't want to spend the
whole video being mad or angry about it
because i still
there's that karma factor there's still
directors are
actors people who worked on it that i
feel bad for to like
now i've gotten to a level where
sometimes if i make a video about an
upcoming movie or something
i'll be lucky enough to get an email
from like someone involved that's like
hey thanks for talking about my movie
that's really nice of you and
that's just that pressure that they
could be watching and i could be saying
something mean
to me i feel like you were such an
influential movement
with the willy's wonderland i think like
i had
no idea about that movie until you
started talking about it
and it was really fun to be a part of
and that was
so so sweet that i got to to do all that
and that was a lot of
fun in that community but that was
another thing where like drama will
start off where people think i'm being
paid to promote it or
i was a plant by a company who was
created and
they started off my channel and stuff
like it's just so funny what people come
up with
for that when i just like i just thought
it was a cool sounding movie
and in the end i had fun with it what do
you do to
me like it's just i know this is a lot
of commitment that you have to do and i
appreciate you taking the time to talk
to me for so long right now no problem
yeah if news pops right now i'm ditching
you
[Laughter]
if we actually just like figured out a
way to like generate it's really sad
where like
news happens and i had to drop
everything i was doing i remember um
when they finally confirmed sonic the
hedgehog 2 which is you know
a movie and a fan base i like being a
part of
um i was at my girlfriend's house we
were gonna have dinner and i was just
like
i'm gonna go to your dad's closet and
record a video real quick
i did that and it was so embarrassing
because like i feel like i turned into
gollum
uh from lord of the rings my precious
i'm just like
trying to rush to get this edited and
say my things there's a quiet down over
there
i completely feel you on that like it's
it's like for us obviously it's like if
it's if a big trailer comes out like
that's where we're we're
known for and i can't tell you how many
times i've had to
be like like kind of the the only
position i'm in like what you talked
about earlier with the
your subs your uh like you don't have to
be first to stuff
the only thing i don't have to be first
to anymore is like a big trailer i could
be late to those and still
like climb up there and um
it's the only thing i got
everything else i'm like i got i got to
be way on top of it and sometimes i'm
um earlier than you and you'll like i
feel like there's still audiences will
still be like
no i go to them for this i go to them
for this i go to them for this but
i completely know the embarrassment of
having to
leave a friend's place and that's part
of the anxiety of doing this is your
life i guess so i've been talking so
much about mental health [ __ ] for some
reason
because there is a big anxiety that does
come with like this came out i had no
idea it was coming out and now i gotta
cover this
uh it's like and because i think i think
what could happen it can feel like you
got these people who are just like
sitting around it's like this is not a
conscious thought but it could feel like
there are people just sitting around
waiting for you
to
this is important for them but it's like
no this is this is just your own mind
exactly
this is what i mean this is it's like
when i listen to conan o'brien interview
like other comedians and they all talk
about comedy
i'm like this is what i think this is
gonna be my interview series is really
gonna talk about youtube
but i i think that's kind of like uh
there because you do
find that weird community of i think
there's a lot when it comes to youtubing
and not even during this discussion but
i i've noticed with like a lot of people
is there's a lot of complaining and i'm
part of that too you know you complain
about algorithm you complain about views
you complain about why is this person
getting views and i'm not getting views
and stuff
that's kind of what bonds us i mean have
you been to like
a vidcon or anything like that yet where
you have like a bunch of youtubers
i'd love to i don't i is that something
you get invited to or you just show up
like i don't even know how that works
or i call them vidcon's a great place to
uh
test your ego if you have it like when
you meet people who are way bigger than
you and stuff like
that now i'm getting fear of fame from
another platform
where i'm trying to master the tick tock
game
you know like it's a very growing uh
demographic and there's an opportunity
for money there what
so little but i'm trying my best and
then there's people like on tick tock
right now movie people that are like
huge on there
that are like nothing on youtube you
know what i mean but it's still that
like
that wanting to master the market of
like having a good
twitter following having a good presence
on youtube and then also
getting tick tock it's like you could
really overwhelm yourself
do you try expanding now with as long as
you've been on the platform
i know there was like a guy in parson
impersonating you on tick tock or
something
oh he's still doing it i haven't been
able to stop him yeah i
i i'm always being told i should you
know like
when it was instagram and twitter you
gotta get instagram twitter blowing up
now it's like tick tock and
and arguably i i otta
but the thing is is like after
this was always supposed to be a
stepping stone in fact i never um
i never thought like you could i i still
have a screenshot of it
of the first year and a half of doing
youtube
i didn't set up adsense and then i was
like oh you got to set up this thing
called adsense
and i remember making like my first
50 cents because the long story short is
john and i had started this channel
together but he was going to college so
eventually
he was pretty much like he was gone
and then i i had to just take the reins
because i wasn't going to college and i
was working 40 hours a week and then
just doing this
and then so i was like well it's got to
be a way to at least like replace the
income
on with you i didn't realize you could
make like actual money on youtube
but it was always supposed to be a
stepping stone was like i've always
wanted to get it
but then this takes up so much time and
then you start you know finding success
here and then validation and all these
things that
arguably you should be fighting from
within and not from external
validation when youtube started going it
was like skyrocketing for me and then it
started going down for me and then i
found my passion again for writing and
then i started going places with that
and then youtube started picking back up
again
and i just and even though it's been
doing so great lately
i haven't been as active with what i
really want to do so i find that i can
get
you seem like you're kind of like uh you
dive into stuff and
i don't uh i can get distracted really
easily and i'm like now if i start
pursuing tick tock or other [ __ ] then
i'm gonna
get you there i'm i'm definitely not
gonna pursue what i want to do
yeah yeah you see just get as many
eyeballs as i can out there
on my channel because i i still have the
fear of like 300k
this is my full-time living for like two
years now thanks to this i'm able like
to move into a house now it just blows
my mind that youtube provided that for
me
congratulations thanks man and i still
fear it's gonna go away tomorrow i still
have that fear that i'm gonna wake up
and
they add a new rule where i can make
like a third of what i make now or
something or they cut my monetization or
i
there's another funnier great cringy
intro youtuber that pops up that
takes all my audience with them like
that's that's just always a fear in the
back of my head
did you grow up uh did you financially
was your family struggle with that no we
were always uh middle class like yeah we
we struggled but like food was always on
the table
i i was able to have a phone i got to do
most regular things there were sometimes
i couldn't do stuff because of money but
for the most part like i had about an
average life so i was never like
i never said like i was poor
it's so weird to say i wasn't poor greg
[Laughter]
youtube has like gotten me to a point
where it's like what am i supposed to do
with this like am i supposed to get into
stocks now am i supposed to
like you get a roth ira or something i
don't even know
i just got a roth ira because
i mean i feel like you got it because we
don't have like a 401k
or anything like that you gotta like
figure out how to say
yeah health insurance because it's like
youtube doesn't provide that
and whatnot and so it's like i i hope
you're saving man
no i am i'm not going crazy i'm not
getting a tesla anytime soon or anything
like that
i blew before because youtube there's a
pewdiepie
thing with the i don't know that i don't
know i still call it the pewdiepie thing
but that's not exactly what it was when
i i think
all the money was pulled up yeah yeah uh
adpocalypse is what they called it i
wasn't a youtuber then but i was
in the game listening to everybody about
that around that time
it [ __ ] us up because
because like it come just like shot down
like 90
and it was terrifying and i didn't save
anything i didn't i had no savings
it was scary this fear that you're
talking about it's weird it's like you
want to
you want to get you have this anxiety in
this rush and you want to you want to
climb and you want to get the views up
and make the money
and you got to be good on camera all
this stuff yeah
and then when you start getting there
then it becomes now i'm afraid i'm going
to lose it all
i'm going to collapse i'm going to
follow her yeah
so it's a fear of am i going to get
there or is it a fear that i'm gonna
lose it
like and i and so as i find myself often
living in
in fear i mean do you kind of have that
feeling too yeah oh i have it all the
time and i'm like scared
about it also like it shouldn't be
scared it's like one of the most freeing
nice jobs out there but like
i don't people think you know like i get
to sleep in all day or just lay down all
day like
i'm constantly stressing about what the
next video is what the next
content is to to make and and whatnot
and
i mean during 2020 it was hard because
there was barely anything going on in
the movie sphere you really had to
dig to make stuff happen and i think you
made it happen yeah like i said like i
really started
i started watching you mainly like a lot
more dirt during 2020 which was like
mightily impressive to see how well yeah
it's obvious man that's [ __ ]
impressive as [ __ ] all these questions
have been gold
have they are we think are we talking
too much about youtubing
i feel like that's kind of like [ __ ]
that'll be our thing
right yeah it's like [ __ ] it let's let's
i think they like it
i mean it's just like an honest
conversation about the anxieties of
doing this is what i'm i'm just trying
to find like background i don't want to
like dive too much into your
you know your past and your i'll bring
it up go ahead man were you abused as a
kid
[Laughter]
just a regular spanking chocolate from
my mom but that's about it
was your mom someone who uh frowned upon
you going
into this you said your dad did it he
was like in the movies was your
my dad was more of the silent brute when
i told him when it was like you know i
told him and he was like
okay and see how it goes and my mom
was the tears that was the sad one she
was crying i was
i remember it was christmas day
we went to starbucks because it was the
only place open and i wanted somewhere
to like tell
her and then i just opened up to her and
i was like mom
i've been lying to you for the past six
months i have not been in college
yeah she's always like so has college
how's everything
you paying your rent you're getting your
work done and i was like yeah classes is
good
finance is done all that's great and i
was doing youtube
and um i wasn't getting paid for it at
that time i was just doing it
for the hell of a little bit as a hobby
hoping it would turn into something but
anyways
yeah i told her she cried it was really
upset about it wow
because you have to from their point of
view it was like they brought me here
for a better life and i was supposed to
be
the college graduate you know in their
mind if you don't have a degree
you're gonna end up homeless in america
which like
even if i don't if youtube didn't work
out i feel like there's something i
could do out there where i don't need my
degree where i can
i'd be just fine if youtube didn't work
out it'd be a struggle
but i feel like i could do it and so
that's where they were really upset
about that but i told them give me a
year and if i can do it
i'll stick to it if not i'll go back to
college i promise and
i'm not in college that's my husky back
there sorry i was like is that skunk
back there what's the hell going on
what did you study in college though
when you were there i was doing
marketing uh and uh business
so i feel like that's maybe why i i was
bet better youtube than maybe a lot of
people who try starting
because i i took it as a business and i
treated each video
as a strategic move of growing that
business and like i also felt like i had
a really good mastery of like
titles and thumbnails to where it's
enticing but it wasn't
clickbait if that makes sense yeah
that's one thing i didn't want to become
is the click fader
i think you've done a great job on that
man i think i i i'm jealous of your
thumbnails like damn look at that
look at that son of kong [ __ ]
thumbnail man that's not
is that a real poster where do you get
that [ __ ]
that's so impressive i was in uh network
marketing the most loved part of
business in the world
but what i learned from that was um
uh the benefits of if you could find a
way to
to work from home and have your uh
business from home you'll rarely hear me
refer to what i do as as a job
it's always been i'm running my own
business essentially
yeah i got the sense i was like i don't
think this guy went to film school
i feel like he learned business or
something everything
i was like phil seems like you're very
knowledgeable you don't seem like a guy
who knows
i feel like you have that uh you you see
the way you talk about things i'm like
i'm getting this business
sense uh from you and i also got to say
i love you i watched a lot of shark tank
yeah you also got the
the cool little one little curl going
down here
i hate what it does that it was at the
whole time i actually like it i think i
look cool but i feel like if i did it on
purpose i'll
look for attention you get in front of
the mirror
i've got my one curl right here man
can i ask her how long you and your
girlfriend have been together yeah so
she got with me when i was it's so funny
because
she's gone with me
sorry we got together we got together i
better at the call center when i was
doing youtube you know as a hobby not
making a dime
reviewing movies thinking that was going
to make me blow up when there's a
million channels reviewing movies she
was the one that always told me no keep
doing it keep doing because i want
i quit like three times just because
it's so draining to make a video and
spend hours on it to talk to 50 people
online
and most of those views are you just
like refreshing checking back to see
what you can do
she was with me from like once they blew
up to like now being able to move to a
house so for
the five years basically damn it's a
good amount of time man she's loyal
yeah she is that now she gets to reap
all the rewards
does she worry you'll get too famous
start cheating on her
she doesn't have that fear no she knows
i would
look at my room i know she is it's
mainly just you on your channel do you
want to like ever do collabs with guests
or anything like that
i do but i get it maybe that's just me
being i'm i'm picky
because i have noticed you know even
there's people i like like you
or or like i have a friend named austin
burke he also has a youtube channel i
don't know
austin you know our heavy spoilers kevin
but like i noticed with those collab
videos
the retention isn't there they'll
they'll severely go down just because
it's like
inviting a new person in bed they just
don't like it or something and
so like i get i get real picky about
bringing people on my channel but i i i
want to i want to because i think it's
fun
so you're not going to invite me on your
channel that's what you're talking about
that's great
john mayer
no i i will but i i just don't know how
to incorporate it what it's like
because with breaking news i'm just like
i gotta call greg
okay so can you get on a camera right
now
i'll just wait for your video to come up
and then i'll just talk about your video
yeah that's our collab but it's so it's
that's like the bizarre part of what we
do is like i'll weirdly get more views
i i could do the same amount of
commentary i do what i'm talking about
what you're talking
like if i cover a 3c films video i'll
get
like i'll get the uh i could get the
same amount of commentary in there that
i want to get in
if we didn't do a reaction yet way more
people will watch
that reaction video than that i was
scared when whenever you first messaged
me and said hey we like your stuff
would you mind if we react i'm like
you're going to kill your channel man
but go ahead
no man i'm glad it's going good
like with the flash logo when you did
that i was like
i heard there's a logo out and he did a
whole video about it he's got to have
something interesting to say
there right that's also my freaking
my freaking powers being able to turn
some 10 second thing into a whole damn
video
just i'm just a huge blabbermouth what
do you do
when you're not youtubing though like
what's your life like
i know it's easy to be addicted to your
phone and researching and all that
oh yeah so i'll always be on my phone
looking for the next big story or
something but
other than that really it right now it's
it's jim trying to control my weight
because i've gotten i've gotten a little
out of hand with the eating and stuff
like that before so before i
i was doing youtube i was actually like
working at like a a learning center
where you had to help kids with homework
and whatnot
oh that required me to be be on my feet
for like eight hours
so like i was i was a pretty
squidward-looking dude you know that
had some squidward photo turned youtube
full-time and i just stayed
sitting here looking at youtube videos
all day and it got worse so it's mainly
the gym right now but it's not going so
great
cause i don't change my eating habit
it's so funny how much you
[ __ ] you say that i'm like man i can i
completely i
i think i just wanted to talk to you
first to identify with you
i see someone confident
because that happened with me like
really i mean i was a
receptionist at a doctor's office
and uh yeah awesome uh everyone loves
going to the doctors
they always want to say hi in a really
upbeat manner then i was doing youtube
like 30 hours a week
and so uh and then you just you never
have time to exercise
so you could literally if you go to like
the oldest video of the real rejects
you could just watch me gain weight and
i like gained a
bunch of weight and then i got all the
fat comments and then
i eventually lost like 30 to 40 pounds
so i'm at that i still stay around that
weight now
because yeah people can be [ __ ] mean
on youtube when it comes
it's not even for that it's just i just
i have to look at myself when i edit and
then just to look at this double chin
it's just kind of like i want that gone
i mean it's the fact that you're like
comfortable enough to talk about it
though i think is usually the first step
of being able to lose weight
is there anything you do in terms of
like i call it like personal development
like
like for me i have to exercise and
meditate at least
like a few times a week glad you brought
that up because i i needed to fix that
you know
because that's something i'm always
telling to my partner you know luckily
now that i'm able to keep her as a
provider and she could just be at home
it's like one of the things i told her
that i believe in is like you could be
at home
and and i'm happy with that you don't
have to be the cook or the laundry or
anything like that
i just don't want you to stop
progressing yourself as a person so like
a book or learn a new skill or something
like that so that that is something i
always want to like
i tried really hard to learn like i
don't know if you know what blender is
like that
to make like cgi animated oh yeah yeah
shorts and stuff i tried learning that
for a sec i couldn't do it i
tried learning after effects a little
better i i'm just like i go to a skill
to skill but if it's too hard i do let
it go
so i need to be better about sticking
with something if not
i want to up my reading but i think i'm
going to do audible which is cheating
[Laughter]
i unders uh the reading i have a hard
time reading fiction for some reason
it's weird as a writer i have a hard
time reading the same way i can't do
science fiction like
i know lord of the rings is a great book
and whatnot but
i i couldn't even like sit down and read
the harry potter books just because my
imagination wasn't
wasn't fully there i i like more like
true crime or grounded in reality
stuff that's me too i try i got the book
i was given the book dune like uh a few
months ago
it's somewhere here and it's only like
three pages open
it's it's like two to three pages to
real like i don't know what the [ __ ] is
i just read it like i don't know it's
even worse because they create
not their own language but they have
their own words and at the back of the
book they have a dictionary for like the
meaning of those words and i'm just like
that's too much i feel bad because
there's so much smart people out there
that's like oh you idiot it's not that
hard
well kids you heard it here first to
make it in youtube you don't need to be
able to read
you can be illiterate and make it happen
anyway
i mean dude i've have you enjoyed have
you enjoyed talking with me chris
thank you man i hope people enjoyed this
i hope it wasn't me just whining
complaining i'm
super thankful for the position i'm in
and i want to make you guys more proud
and entertain the masses but uh
yeah i had a great time here greg i feel
like we had a really good relaxing time
i feel like this conversation is so
beneficial
way more for you and i than it will be
for anyone who ever listens to this
discussion
if you made it this far and you're
listening to this thank you it means a
lot to both me
and greg's retention time what would you
say
i guess what i would say is like what
what would you
try to phrase this in a way that doesn't
sound super cliche to end this off with
are you gonna make me give advice is
that what you're about to make me do
yeah and maybe i'll be like [ __ ] why
haven't i applied that after all this
time
no i mean it really is like you hurt i
feel like i'm just an average of guy
there's nothing huge or special about me
so like if you at all
have an interest in youtube just like do
it and you'd be surprised
you know how far you could take it and
how great of a community they could be
out there it's it's just really if you
have a passion for something
do it okay because like as much as i
talk about like here where it's like i
feel like it could go away at any time
those other jobs i was talking about
learning center at a call center
those places they're now out of business
and not working so they
they were also just as unpredictable so
why not do something like youtube or
something that
gives you some passion is that good or
is that too cliche i could do it again
greg
no no no i think that was great i mean i
i think you're right like
i i would tell people i've told people
before
that if i feel like as long as you
s find ways to stay true to yourself
it's because it takes i think it takes
some work
getting used to just being comfortable
and being yourself on camera like you
can
go back to my early videos it's horrible
i i sound so forced
that's that's the thing is and even for
someone like like what i envy about
people like a lot of people i admire
watch is that and i want to kind of
reshift this
for the real rejects is that we're doing
like
sorry uh i don't even know i said sorry
i just said sorry
you're just so polite you're just gonna
apologize
i think i'm sorry for saying sorry
i think uh you find stuff to do and you
don't put out videos every single day
you you do them like when you find
something that really hooks you and then
for me i've
i've kind of gotten caught in the trap
of i feel like i gotta put out [ __ ] like
every single day when i'm more like
i kind of want to pedal this back a
little bit especially after
like the months have been so good to us
and then like the
past three to four days have not been
good that great for us
so i'm like but i don't like this
feeling of feeling like i just gotta do
so you can get kind of yeah it's easy to
feel like you're just going through the
motions instead of feeling the
enthusiasm and passion of actually
filming and stuff
and uh i don't like i hate that feeling
and sometimes i gotta like step away for
like a day or two so i could find that
feeling again
so i kind of want to do a little bit
more of what you're doing which is like
i feel like doing this
so i'm gonna do it as opposed to i gotta
put something out i just gotta put
something yeah you know
because that could be the trap i fall
into uh easily
so guys don't seek validation just be
yourself
take it from two people who are seeking
validation and comparing yourself to
others all the time
i hope it i mean i feel like it's real
it's personable yeah
yeah yeah credits
[Laughter]
all right thank you chris for doing this
man this is seriously a blast dude no
thank you thank you for having me greg i
really appreciate you man
and thank you guys subscribe to three c
films done so already he's
doing so much better than than heavy
spoilers
he can suck i hate every spoilers i told
him
i'm gonna hit him i saw your tweet be
like
i'd pay for that i'd watch that
you could have his wife go up against
your girlfriend and then
you yeah is this a i keep calling him
paul
i don't know where kevin spoilers came
from he decided yeah
that imposter i i sometimes message him
and i'm like am i saying the right name
am i being a dick about this
uh all right chris thanks for being here
man i'll i'll hit you up in text
yes peace guys
[Music]